(tense dramatic music)
- I love that you
came to my house,
and you broke up
with me in my space,
and I'm gonna I think about
that every time I'm here.
That's great, that
is so perfect for me.
It's the best thing that's ever
happened to me. (stammering)
- Okay, wh-where else
was I supposed to do it?
'Cause you won't
come to my house.
- Oh, here he is,
- I wanted to-
- the puppet master is back.
- But I'm not, I'm not,
no, I'm not the puppet master.
- Then why are you
doing this to me?
- It's true, you won't
come to my house.
You said my apartment looks like
two rats just (beep)
in it every (beep) day.
- Oh, right, like,
thank you for that.
I'm a bitch, thank you.
(quick beatbox music)
(bubbles popping)
(latch clicks)
(briefcase thuds)
- [Stanley] Where is he?
- Stanley.
- Huh?
- (gasps lightly)
What's going on?
- Oh, come on, I know
you've been cheating on me.
- You're being ridiculous,
Stanley.
- Andrea, enough is enough.
I know you have been (beep)
a dog behind my back!
- What?
A dog?
A dog? That is insane!
- Then why did I find this
in the laundry room, huh?
(toy clatters)
(dog barks)
- Oh my God. (laughs
incredulously)
He's here right now, isn't he?
He's in my house right now!
- Stanley! No, wait!
(dog growling)
(dog growls)
- You!
(dog snarls)
(Stanley screaming)
(Andrea gasps)
(Stanley shouting)
(floor thuds)
(dog snarling)
(blow thuds)
(Andrea yelps)
(blows thudding)
(Stanley yelling)
(frames clattering)
(Stanley grunting)
(blows thudding)
(dog snarling)
(Stanley shouting)
(dog panting)
(dog barks)
(Stanley panting)
(dog whimpers)
Oh.
I see.
You
need to know
your dog ruined a
10-year marriage.
(dog whimpering)
And you can go to hell.
(dog lapping)
Yeah, he's cute.
He's cute, I can see
why you like him.
(file rasping)
- So what do you
wanna do tonight?
Like, I was thinking
maybe we could meet up
with Amy and Brad,
and, like, before that,
we could go to Angelo's,
and before that we
could, like, just go buy-
- Meegan!
I have something to say.
(exhales sharply)
I had to say it in person
because it's,
it's, like, super important.
- Okay.
- Um,
I know this is sudden,
(soft somber music)
but, like, I've been thinking
about this for a while
and I know this is something
that needs to happen.
I'm breaking up with you.
- Cool. Love it.
Totally fine with that.
- Re-really?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I thought...
I was,
I was really worried that
you were gonna be, like, mad.
- Mad?
Oh my God. Are you kidding me?
No! Of course I'm not mad.
People grow apart.
It happens.
It's, like, part of life.
No, I'm totally fine.
Like, love it.
Love it. Love it.
- Um. (clears throat)
(soft tender music)
So...
Uh, um, you know, we,
we had a good run.
Yeah.
(tender music swelling)
D-d-don't be stranger.
- Can I just,
(music drops)
can I ask why?
- Why?
- Yeah. Like, whatevs.
(low tense music)
Like, I'm doing
some work on myself
and like trying to
grow as a person, so
- Cool, cool.
- I'd really, like,
appreciate to know why.
- Yeah. Um, okay, yeah.
(tense music building)
That's, like, you know,
I think that you're
kind of like a,
a controlling person-
- Thank you.
Thank you for that.
That's nice. Thank you for that.
- Cool. No problem.
- Yeah.
- So you know what
your problem is, Andre?
- What?
- You keep tabs on people.
Every little thing
somebody does,
you have to keep a tab of it.
- Wait, I, I,
I can't tell if
you're angry or not.
- I'm not.
Totally not angry.
- Okay.
- No, I'm excited. It's good.
It's just, like,
you said your piece,
- Mm-hmm.
- and I just think
that I deserve the human
decency to say my piece.
- Right. Right.
- Is that,
is that not okay, or?
- No, no, no, it's...
No, of course. Of course.
- You're a controlling,
manipulative person.
Everyone says it.
- I, I, I don't think that I am.
- Yes, you are, Andre.
Yes, you (beep) are.
- Okay, n-now, you
sound pretty angry.
- I'm not angry!
I'm not angry.
I'm fine!
I love it!
I love that you
came to my house,
and you broke up
with me in my space,
and I'm gonna think about
that every time I'm here.
That's great. That
is so perfect for me.
It's the best thing that's
ever happened. (stammering)
- Okay, wh-wh-where else
was I supposed to do it?
'Cause you won't
come to my house.
- Oh, here he is,
- I wanted to-
- the puppet master is back.
- But I'm not, I'm not,
no, I'm not the puppet master.
- Then why are you
doing this to me?
- It's true, you won't
come to my house.
You said my apartment looks like
two rats just (beep)
in it every (beep) day.
- Oh, right, like,
thank you for that.
I'm a bitch, thank you.
- I didn't, no, I didn't
say bitch, I didn't,
all I said was that-
- So which is it?
Am I evil or am I a bitch?
- No, no, you're not
evil, Meegan. You're not-
- Well, then, why
are you punishing me?
- I'm not, I'm
not punishing you!
I'm not-
- You broke up with me,
and I'm not supposed
to feel punished?
Who thinks like that?
- (stammering) I don't know!
I'm, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry. Okay, Meegan?
I, I guess I didn't
think it through!
- Well, it's like too late now.
I mean, we're done.
- No, it's not too late.
Meegan! Meegan, seriously.
I just, I, I, I,
I had a feeling that
I thought was true,
and clearly, clearly,
it wasn't true.
- I'm so confused.
Like, like, are you
breaking up with me
or are you not
breaking up with me?
- Meegan!
I'm not breaking up with you!
(tense music drops)
- Okay, cool, so what
do you wanna do tonight?
Like, I wanna hang
out with Amy and Brad,
but maybe before that,
(intense ominous music)
we could go to Angelo's,
and before that, we
could go buy some things.
- What just happened?
- Oh, thank you.
- I wish I could just
stay at my old place,
but I can't afford the new rent.
- Yeah, moving sucks.
You know, strangers
handling your belongings.
The movers always
break something.
- Oh, no, I can't afford
professional movers.
I'm moving myself this Saturday.
(dramatic ominous music)
I'm gonna do most of the
small stuff just going back
and forth with my hatchback.
Oh, do you think you can
borrow your roommate's van?
You can help me with
some of the big stuff?
(ominous music softens)
- Um...
Yeah.
You know what?
I've been thinkin' a lot lately,
and I think we need to
spend some time apart.
N-not to break up.
No, I just, I just,
just some time.
Time apart to figure
ourselves out,
and, and, and then,
and then we come back
together stronger, you know?
- But this is coming
outta nowhere.
- No, it's not.
I've, I have, I have
tried to tell you
like a, like a million
different ways,
but y-you don't listen.
See, that's the thing,
is that you, you never listen.
I don't need this
time apart for me.
I need this time apart for us.
How long do you think it's
gonna take you to move?
- Okay.
This is about the move.
You don't wanna help me move.
- Wha-what?
I would, I would love
to help you move.
That's what boyfriends do.
Claire!
- I just think that
it's a weird coincidence
that you need space right
when I'm about to move.
- Oh my God!
Oh my God.
I am so sorry
that I didn't plan my emotional
turmoil around your move.
Look at, look at your face. See?
And now, you've
assumed the worst of me
because you do that,
and that's why we
need to spend time
apart from each other.
- That is not fair!
- Not f-fair?
Babe,
all I'm asking for is 12
lousy hours this Saturday.
- Okay, fine!
- Okay, fi-fine? (sighs)
- We'll move on Sunday.
- 48 hours.
I don't know what
I was thinking.
12 hours
is nowhere near enough time
to do what I need to do to
make our relationship stronger.
See, you got me all confused,
and you know what?
I love you, but I
gotta get outta here.
I can't, I just can't.
I don't...
I'm so confused right now.
(phone chimes)
I feel, I, I can't think,
and the walls are
closing in on me,
and I just don't
know what to do.
I...
- That was my landlord.
He says he doesn't want
to lose me as a tenant,
so he is not going
to raise my rent.
(phone beeps)
Now, I don't have
to leave my place.
- And I don't need time apart
(soaring romantic music)
because we're perfect together.
Will you marry me?
(romantic music drops)
- You're painting my apartment.
- Of course I'm
painting your apartment,
that's what boyfriends do.
When, exactly, do you
think that's gonna happen?
- Oh, go on like that.
(energetic dance music)
- What? That's amazing.
- He's so good at this.
- Amazing!
- I know! Look at your points.
(group chattering)
- Oh, oh! Oh!
- Oh, look at that!
Nice. Nice! (laughs)
(group applauding)
- Dude.
(video game beeping)
You have absolutely
mastered this game.
- Yeah, well, since Sheila left,
I've been spending a lot of time
- Here we go.
- playing the game.
- You're doing really good.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- That's why we're here, man!
Help you get over
her
and check out this
awesome new game you have!
- Yay.
- You know, I left
something in another room.
Um, excuse me, everyone.
(chipper video game music)
- Should we? Sure?
- Oh, he still has the
sensors on. (chuckles)
- Oh, look.
- Is that him in his room?
- Yeah. You can see
him, that's funny.
What is he doing?
Is he, is he on his knees?
Did he drop to his knees?
- Oh! (chuckles awkwardly)
- Aw. No, no, no...
- He's probably looking for-
- No, look, he's, he's crying.
- Oh.
- He's crying.
Oh no.
- He's just...
- No, no, he's shuddering.
- Just shaking.
- He's shuddering.
Is he fetal?
Yeah, he curled up.
Look at that, he's fetal.
- Hey, Craig, buddy!
You all right up there?
- Uh, yeah, Bob!
I-I-I'm coming right out.
(fast techno game music)
- Oh, he, um...
- Hey.
Man.
You all right?
- Yes! Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah.
It's just my sinuses
(sniffs) are acting up.
Yeah!
Yeah. I, um...
I was just, you know, I was
just thinking about Sheila,
and you know what?
I am, I am totally over her.
- Awesome!
- Awesome.
- Hey, let's get
this party started!
- Sure. Yeah.
Oh.
(frame scrapes)
Uh...
I forgot to get rid of
this picture of Sheila.
Excuse me.
- Hey, maybe leave the sensor
so one of us can play!
(chipper video game music)
(Bob sighs)
- Oh, he's dancing.
He's dancing with the photo.
Is he, he's doing,
he's doing this with it,
is he kissing it?
- Guys, we don't...
- I think he's kissing it.
- You know what, I'm
gonna turn this off
'cause we don't need to-
- You change it, and you die.
He's undoing his buckle.
Look at this.
His pants are coming off,
his pants are coming off.
Oh, God.
- Yeah.
- No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
- Okay, that's happening.
- Oh no, no, no.
- Oh my gosh.
- Is he, he's,
he is totally on the bed.
- Yeah.
- He's totally flat on the bed.
- [Bob] Oh, maybe he's
shaking a can of hairspray.
- Oh God!
- Gross.
- Ugh.
- Oh, gross.
(girls groaning)
(techno game music)
- We, we shouldn't be.
Okay, you know...
- Is he reaching
down for his foot?
- I don't-
- That's his foot, isn't it?
Is that his foot?
- I don't...
- Hm...
- And coming back, coming back.
(muttering)
(Craig exhales sharply)
- I am sorry, everybody.
(rapid techno game music)
Would you like me
to make some snacks?
- Wash your hands first?
(video game chirps)
(warbling game music)
(PA speaker warbling)
(wife sighs)
(machine beeping steadily)
- Don.
- Yes?
I'm here.
- Promise you'll
never forget about me.
- (sighs softly) Yes.
Of course.
(soft somber music)
- Promise me you'll take
care of our little girl.
Love her.
- Yes.
(sniffles) With all my heart.
- Promise me you'll
stay strong for her.
- (sniffling) Yes.
Yes.
I promise.
- And promise me you'll never
sleep with another woman.
(tutting softly)
- I hear you.
- Promise me you'll take
care of Mr. McFluffyTail.
- Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
That cat will be (sniffs) the
most loved cat in the world.
- And that you
won't look at porn.
- Mm...
(wailing softly)
- Huh?
- Uh... (stammering)
- Is that yes?
(gibbering)
- Check.
- No pornography.
- Buster Brown says what?
- Is that a yes?
- (sputtering) Yo better believe
I heard what you said, girl.
- You love me, right?
- Yes! I love you.
Yes.
- And we're soulmates, right?
- Yes.
- So you will never, ever,
ever think of someone else
while masturbating, right?
- Message received.
- I don't understand,
is that a yes?
(speaks Spanish)
- Is that a promise?
- Your request has been filed.
- Say you promise.
- Fuhgeddabou...
Huh?
- I need to hear you say it.
- It.
- I, say, "I promise."
- You promise.
- You,
you promise?
Say it.
- Okay, I promise.
- No air quotes.
♪ Promises are things
that lovers have ♪
Say it.
Say it!
- I promise.
I promise.
- What are you promising?
- I promise what you said.
- (sighs) Fine, forget it.
- Yes.
I mean,
okay.
- Will you at least promise
to go see my mom every day?
- So zero pornography? Done.
I like that.
Nurse!
Fix my wife!
(sobbing)
Don't touch me right
now. (stammering)
Not all about you.
(upbeat funk music)
♪ All I want, yeah ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪